bild reporterin kollegin annika rasch
tolles panorama und gerade wurde
gefrühstückt jetzt gibt es das erste
wichtige treffen welches ganz genau
annika
genau das erste große treffen findet
bilateral stadt zwischen olaf scholz und
eben dem amerikanischen präsidenten die
beiden um 10 uhr 30 treffen sich die
beiden neben dem schloss in einem
gebäude in einem gipfel gebäude
sozusagen neben dem schloss und eine
stunde später kommen dann eben die
anderen staatschefs die dann eben im
anschluss eine halbe stunde später um 12
uhr von olaf scholz begrüßt werden also
ganz wichtiges zeigen gleich für die
deutsch-amerikanische freundschaft das
ist ja damals von dem letzten gipfel
dort auf schloss elmau auch ausgegangen
wir kennen dieses berühmte bild obama
merkel auf der bank das war das foto was
im gedächtnis geblieben ist von diesem
gipfel hier sehen wir es gerade noch mal
also merkel man hat nie richtig
rausfinden können was hat sie in dem
moment im obama erklärt aber dieses foto
allein das hatte eine extreme
symbolkraft diese bank die sollen heute
noch mal ganz groß rauskommen annika
genau wir haben exklusiv gehört das eben
diese bank wieder eine ganz wichtige
rolle spielen soll heute
ähnlich wieder g7 strandkorb in
heiligendamm wir erinnern uns wie du
eben schon gesagt hast an dieses obama
merkel foto vor dieser bank diese bank
soll nicht im original aber
wahrscheinlich nachgebaut und verlängert
wieder zum einsatz kommen also eventuell
nimmt er dieses mal nicht nur ein
staatsgast platz sondern auch gleich
mehrere wenn sie eben verlängert werden
sollen und wie gesagt das ist halt eben
auch das erste gipfeltreffen ohne merkel
und obama und auch das erste
familienfoto am ende nach 16 jahren ohne
eine frau
also das wird heute das foto werden die
lange g7 bank wir haben gerade den
strandkorb noch mal gesehen damals
wladimir putin noch dabei war damals war
es g8 in heiligendamm annika danke für
deine informationen und dieser
strandkorb der soll heute durch die bank
eingetauscht werden also die obama
merkel bank wir hoffen dann dass die
sieben nicht die probleme auf genau
diese schieben auf die lange bank also
dieses foto von damals der lange
strandkorb heute soll er nach unseren
informationen eine lange bank werden
dort von schloss elmau auf der dann alle
g7 staats und regierungschefs platz
nehmen sollen dass also das erste
wichtige fototermine die dieser g7
gipfel heute bringen will und auch das
bringt dieser g7 leute die nur mit einem
ziel zu diesem gipfel gefahren sind um
ärger zu machen die polizei hat sich
dafür gerüstet 18.000 einsatzkräfte
18.000 bild polizeireporter cal kai
media zugeschaltet er den blick die
ganze zeit auf all diese einsatzkräfte
hat karl gibt uns einen überblick was
genau machen die im moment sind die
schon bei sie gab es schon einzelne
scharmützel was haben die eben moment
jetzt schon zu tun die polizisten
ja ich kann die frage direkt weitergeben
an die polizei sprecherin carolin
england die hierfür die polizei den g7
einsatz betreut als pressesprecherin
frau erinnert können sie uns erst mal
allgemein sagen sieht man hier schon
demonstranten die nur krawall im blick
haben die hier alles in schutt und asche
legen wollen nein dies sehen wir gott
sei dank nicht bislang ist hier in
garmisch partenkirchen wirklich alles
friedrich friedlich wir haben im camp
rund 300 bewohner aktuell das könnten
auch noch ein paar mehr werden und gegen
13 uhr startet ja dann hier die
versammlung es sind 1000 teilnehmer
angemeldet wir werden sehen wie viele es
dann sind vermutlich immer die
bayerische polizei kennt für jeden
demonstranten mindestens einen
polizisten wie sieht das aus wie viele
polizisten sind dann heute hier im
einsatz also wir sind ja mit einem sehr
hohen kräfteaufgebot hier im einsatz
insgesamt rund um den gesamten g7 gipfel
mit 18.000 einsatzkräften aus ganz
deutschland bayern aber natürlich auch
aus dem benachbarten ausland wie viele
genau jetzt hier in garmisch
partenkirchen sind das lässt sich so
einfach gar nichts sagen es verteilt
sich ja auch auf den kompletten
landkreis aber wir sind auf jeden fall
mit einem sehr hohen kräfteeinsatz hier
vor ort es gibt jetzt ein bisschen
streit um diesen shuttle der morgen
demonstranten in sicht und höhe des
schlosses bringen soll wie wie läuft das
da ab ja es gibt ja durch das
landratsamt rattenkirchen die die
zuständige behörde sind einen bescheid
für diese versammlung und der sieht vor
dass 50 versammlungsteilnehmer am
bahnhof in kreis von der polizei
aufgenommen werden mit polizeifahrzeugen
dann in den sicherheitsbereich gebracht
werden und dort ihre versammlung
abhalten können genau das sind jetzt so
die ersten eindrücke aus garmisch
partenkirchen ich war gestern auch in
münchen unterwegs dort gab es eine demo
mit 4000 demonstranten gegen den g 7
gipfel demonstriert haben die polizei
hatte im vorfeld mit einer hohen
dreistelligen anzahl an mitglieder des
schwarzen blocks gerechnet das waren
dann aber in der spitze so würd ich
sagen 200 es gab einmal kurz ein
bisschen gerangel als eine festnahme
getätigt worden ist da musste dann auch
gewalt angewendet werden ansonsten war
das gestern auch für mich verhältnisse
im jahr vorher linksextrem eigentlich
sehr sehr langweilig da war eigentlich
alles friedlich selbst für mich nur
verhältnisse im doch sehr ruhig aber
dieser shuttle service sehr interessiert
mich nochmal karl also das ist ja
spektakulär heißt das da steigt dann
auch der schwarze block bei der polizei
sozusagen ein in diesem shuttle service
und lässt sich zum ort transportieren um
dann dazu demonstrieren
ja das ist so geplant die demonstranten
lehnt als auch der zeit ab man hat ihn
das angeboten das landratsamt
garmisch-partenkirchen denn das
versammlungsrecht das ist ja wirklich
und in deutschland ein sehr hohes gut
die sollen dann wird einem polizeibus
haben polizei shuttle in sicht und hören
näher gebracht werden die lehnen das
aber offenkundig ab und wollen damit
eigenen bussen hinfahren die frage ist
jetzt ob sie das dann genehmigt bekommen
tendenz eher nein denn das hat dann vor
sieben jahren auch gegeben und da hat
man dann das angebot der polizei nicht
angenommen also ja wie das dann
weitergeht da müssen wir dann morgen
nochmal darüber berichten wie das dann
letztendlich stattfinden sollen und was
dann natürlich auch elf heute dann im
bus sitzen können ich denke mal dass das
nicht die radikalsten sein werden ja das
denke ich auch danke teil absurde
situationen bei denen dann den bus
einsteigen um anschließend dort gegen
die zu demonstrieren und sie zu
attackieren möglicherweise danke dir für
den moment weiter zu unserem bild
reporter jörg völkerling ja auch schon
mittendrin war bei diesen ersten
demonstrationen jetzt auf dem gipfel
steht von oben herabschaut auf eine ganz
besondere location jörg
tatsächlich wir stehen jetzt hier an der
sprungschanze wo das neujahrsspringen
normalerweise stattfindet und hinter mir
ist das olympiastadion von
garmisch-partenkirchen wie der kollege
schule gesagt hat dem
ministerpräsidenten schröder ging es am
flughafen schöne bilder an schloss elmau
geht es um schöne bilder für die
staatschef und natürlich ist das ganze
hier auch eine leistungsschau der
bayerischen polizei wir können jetzt mal
hinter und gucken hier unten wo die
skispringer normalerweise lampen da
befindet sich jetzt sozusagen der g7
knast die gefangenensammelstelle es sind
hier in kürzester zeit
rsn für bis zu 150 gefangene aus dem
boden gestampft worden das sind
büroräume für die justiz für richter
staatsanwälte für verteidiger geschaffen
worden aber alle hoffen natürlich dass
all diese vorsichtsmaßnahmen nicht
gebraucht werden und dass die aktivisten
hier friedlich bleiben wir können auch
den blick schweifen lassen direkt von
diesem olympiastadion in einer geraden
linie nach hinten ganz hinten darunter
bald beginnt da ist das grandhotel
sonderlichen wo der thailändische könig
normalerweise passiert und der hätte
auch einen sehr guten blick auf dieses
camp wo bis momentan noch 300 leute drin
sind und
von mir aus rechts gesehen ist auch der
hubschrauberlandeplatz von wo aus diese
hubschrauber super puma in den
einsatzraum starten und es gab gestern
hier blieb sie am ort bisher sehr ruhig
es gab eine aktion die sehr spektakulär
und natürlich auch auf spektakuläre
bilder ausgerichtet war das war ein
greenpeace aktivisten die richtung
zugspitze hochgeklettert sind auf 1800
metern und dort mit fackeln mit
überdimensionalen teelichtern ein peace
zeichen in den berg gezeichnet haben
just kurz vor der ankunft des us
präsidenten joe biden die polizei hat
sie dann gewähren lassen aber das war
natürlich bei nacht und nebel bei den
temperaturen da oben unwegsamen gelände
eine sehr waghalsige aktion man kann
unser bild reporter jörg völkerling dort
von der sprungschanze in garmisch
partenkirchen wo im moment nichts mit
springen ist wohnen der g7 knast ist als
alle der sicherheitsvorkehrung für
diesen g7-gipfel danke dir für den
moment wir schauen noch mal drauf auf
all das was an reportern für uns
unterwegs ist volle kraft dort für
diesen g7 gipfel in diesen stunden und
für die nächsten tage für völkerling
annika rasch karl kam ralf schuler
angelika hellemann als sie sind im
einsatz bei diesem großen gipfel der
staats und regierungschefs hier in
bayern hier bei uns vor der haustür
sozusagen die sind mittlerweile fast
alle eingetrudelt einer kommt noch das
sind rudow der kanadische premier er ist
noch auf dem weg ansonsten der japaner
gerade angekommen am flughafen und in
der nacht eben das highlight der us
präsident joe biden der auch dann
begrüßt von markus söder jetzt das
livebild dort von münchen vom flughafen
sie sehen roter teppich noch ausgerollt
wir warten auf justins rudow und dann
ist die g7 truppe dort wirklich noch
komplett auf schloss elmau und es kann
losgehen mit dem gipfel werde es gerade
schon gehört vor dem gipfel direkt vor
dem start schon das erste vier augen
gespräch von unserem kanzler mit dem us
präsident joe biden das macht dann den
auftrag die beiden werden sich auch
äußern dann am späten vormittag nach
diesem ersten vier-augen-gespräch
gigantisch das sicherheitsaufgebot
18.000 einsatzkräfte am agrarischen
gesagt hubschrauber in der luft alles
abgesperrt die dörfer rund um das
schloss elmau seit tagen total
abgeschottet sie gleich in einer festung
und bild hat alle details von der
polizei was dort alles aufgefahren wurde
in dieser region
weit reichende sperrzone rund um schloss
schloss elmau rein und raus nur mit
passierschein der äußere gürtel der
verläuft sogar mitten durch die berge
dort also das war ein gigantischer
aufwand dort diese zäune zu bauen diese
sperrzone zu errichten
wir schauen aber darauf auf die ganzen
eingesetzten kräfte und alles was man da
im einsatz hat
diensthundeführer
kommunikations beamte
polizeireiter fahrradfahrer kräfte aus
allen anderen bundesländern und sogar
aus dem ausland also mehr geht nicht man
will nichts dem zufall überlassen dass
das gigantische
sicherheitsaufgebot für diesen g7-gipfel
hier bei uns vor der haustür und wir
haben einmal geschaut was sich am
protest dort aufstellt vor und rund um
diesen g7-gipfel
noch hat er nicht begonnen der g 7
gipfel in ellmau schon legen
krawallmacher wieder mit dem zündeln los
die ersten polizeiautos sie brennen
werden von den extremisten im schutz der
nacht in brand gesteckt
mobilisierungen zu diesem thema werden
wir natürlich auch hier im linksextremen
bereich ermitteln aber bislang haben wir
noch keine tatsächliche die bilder jetzt
in münchen sie rufen schlimme
erinnerungen wach 2017 g20-gipfel in
hamburg und die stadt brennt chaoten aus
ganz europa pilgern in die hansestadt
randalieren sorgen für verwüstungen
liefern sich straßenschlachten mit der
polizei
der gastgeber des g20 gipfels der
damalige erste bürgermeister olaf scholz
heute ist der bundeskanzler und erneut
gastgeber dieses mal g 7 in ellmau und
wieder drohen chaoten mit schwerer
randale
letztendlich haben wir uns auf die
gefahren genau solche anschläge auch
eingestellt und das wird natürlich für
die eingesetzten polizeibeamten beamten
bayerns des bundes aus den anderen
bundesländern natürlich jetzt ein ja
nahezu tägliches thema werden bis der
gipfel dann erfolgreich wie ich hoffe
abgeschlossen ist die politik sie will
bilder wie in hamburg dieses mal
unbedingt vermeiden zum
sicherheitskonzept gehört auch der g7
knast das olympia skistadion von
garmisch partenkirchen normalerweise
landen hier skispringer während des g 7
gipfels könnten aber krawallmacher hier
landen das skistadion es ist der g7
knast ein containerdorf extra für den
mega gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs gebaut bild schaut sich
in dem containerdorf um zeigt wo
krawallmacher und chaoten festgesetzt
werden der vollklimatisierte komplex mit
insgesamt 260 containern er liegt
inmitten der idyllischen berglandschaft
das innere lange sterile flure große
voll ausgestattete büros die 50 zellen
sie bieten platz für insgesamt 150
häftlinge notschalter für den
toilettengang inklusive auch die
personalstärke kann sich sehen lassen
250 einsatzkräfte dazu richter anwälte
und ärzte im schichtdienst der g7 knast
ist voll ausgestattet rund um die uhr in
betrieb die gewahrsams zeiten sollen
kurz sein die krawallmacher alle
polizeilichen maßnahmen schnell
durchlaufen erlassen die vor ort richter
einen haftbefehl geht es sofort richtung
echten knast bilder wie in hamburg sie
sollen diesmal unbedingt vermieden
werden der g7 knast im olympiastadion er
soll einen ruhigen gipfel garantieren ja
das sagt die polizei was sagt die andere
seite wer sind die protestler die diesen
gipfel ja um jede macht verhindern
wollten in den vergangenen tagen wochen
und monaten haben uns diese protestler
genau angeschaut
g7 gipfel treffen das weckt auch immer
erinnerungen an demos und
ausschreitungen wie im jahr 2007 in
heiligendamm
unzählige gewaltbereite g7 gegner
liefern sich gefechte mit der polizei
auch dieses jahr g7 demonstranten sind
auf den straßen liefern sich bereits
einen tag vor beginn des gipfels heftige
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei so
wie hier auf der
in münchen ein vorgeschmack auf das was
noch kommen wird denn die gegner des
gipfeltreffens sie haben garmisch im
griff noch bevor die mächtigsten sieben
politiker zum gipfel auf schloss elmau
überhaupt ein treffen sind die
demonstranten schon vor ort nur wenige
kilometer vom tagungsort des g 7 gipfel
entfernt schlagen sie ihr camp
aufrichten sich ein auf tagelangen
protest die erste großdemo in garmisch
partenkirchen ist für heute angekündigt
mit 3000 teilnehmern
das lager der g7 gegner zunächst nicht
ganz so groß es ist ausgelegt auf 750
menschen da gehen wir jetzt mal davon
aus dass er damit auch hinkommen ist hat
auch sozusagen gespräche gegeben also
falls sie sagen doch mehr kommen würden
aber auch die sollten versorgt sein mit
600 kilogramm nudeln und 100 kilogramm
orangen die unter anderem im camp
vorrätig sind mehr als gut vorbereitet
ist aber vor allem die polizei die mit
einem großaufgebot vor ort ist also wir
haben jetzt in der spitze am wochenende
rund 18.000 einsatzkräfte der polizei es
sind einsatzkräfte natürlich aus bayern
aber wir werden unterstützt von allen
bundesländern von der bundespolizei und
auch sogar von österreich und anderen
europäischen ländern um das geschehen
überblicken zu können waren die
einsatzkräfte in schwindelerregender
höhe rund
2300 meter hoch gehalten die polizisten
auf einer berghütte das gesamte areal im
blick
wie nah die demonstrationen dem
gipfeltreffen kommen werden ob es auch
proteste am schloss elmau selbst geben
wird ist noch offen
überlegungen der polizei ausgewählte
demonstranten mit einem shuttle
direktanschluss zu fahren hatten
zunächst kritik ausgelöst
und jetzt so heiko teggatz von der
gewerkschaft der polizei dort zuständig
für die bundespolizei grüße sie herzlich
bei bild leihverträge schon gehört auch
einreisekontrollen die haben in den
vergangenen stunden und tagen schon
mächtig stau dort verursacht
einreisekontrollen woran erkennen denn
ihre kollegen von der bundespolizei wäre
möglicherweise dort ärger machen könnte
aber schloss elmau und drumherum
ja meine zunächst mal übermorgen auch
zurück aus garmisch meine meine kollegen
sind dort vor ort eingesetzt und der
notwendigen polizeilichen spürsinn ist
vorhanden also die erkennen sehr wohl ob
jemand jetzt
zu einer zu einer gegendemonstration
nach garmisch reisen möchte oder eben
ganz normal im urlaub fährt als martha
sind halt hoch und hohen
sicherheitsmaßnahmen werden dort an den
grenzen auch du sagen lückenlose
kontrollen durchgeführt durch die
bundespolizei aber was machen sie mit
denen also wer darf dahin und wen fangen
sie im vorfeld schon ab denn wir hören
etliche mitglieder dieses sogenannten
schwarzen blocks sind dann ja eben doch
da mehrere hundert offenbar also die hat
man dann dahin reisen lassen andere
sortiert man aus
nun ja das ist halt schwierig für für
die für die polizei und so eine woche
lang angesetzten groß als dass da
wirklich jeden einzelnen haus zu binden
aber wenn sie reisebewegungen haben an
den grenzen die in die hunderttausende
gehen dann kann es schon mal durchaus
vorkommen dass da
einige einige durch flutschen sage ich
jetzt mal und dann tatsächlich auch
diese diese camps dort erreichen wo wir
feststellen dass die sieben bezug da ist
dann stellen wir die personalien fest
von denen von den personen führen die
befragungen durch an der grenze und dann
nicht dass in einem essener eingesetzten
kollegen ob da die weiterreise an der
ganze gestattet wird oder eben nicht wir
berichten so aus gebe ich auch über die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen weil wir uns
eben g20 hamburg so sehr in den gliedern
noch stärker als deswegen ganz kurze
prognose wird das ein friedlicher gipfel
jahren ein also ich gehe davon aus dass
werden friedlicher gipfel weil die
bayerischen sicherheitspolitik als
anders aufgestellt ist als in einer
freien und hansestadt hamburg also der
freistaat bayern hat ja über jahrzehnte
hinweg diese bildung von linksradikalen
linksradikalen zonen wie in hamburg die
rote flora beispielsweise nicht geduldet
und das zahlt sich dann halt aus bei
solchen bei solchen events danke
herzlich an den gewerkschaftschef
zuständig für die bundespolizei bei der
deutschen gewerkschaft der polizei heiko
teggatz danke danke und so kann protest
eben auch aussehen so friedlich ein
gigantisches peace-zeichen am abend am
späten abend als es dunkel wurde in die
berge gezeichnet mit feuer toller
protest optisch greenpeace steckt hinter
dieser aktion
kerzen am berg für die g 7